I think it's going to take a few decades
for India to become a superpower unless
we solve the basic problems of our
poverty the infrastructure and lying our
own people to create wealth it's not
going to be easy for a kids here forced
our people to either not be proud of
what we are doing or to take their money
out of the country it's only in the last
one decade that reforms or a little more
than that that reforms are taking place
these are not enough we have miles and
miles to go and I do not have any kind
of seriousness about that if we are
really really want to become a
superpower what we have to do this
unshackle our businesses totally you
have to allow the global best practices
to come in free we have to allow the
ingenuity of 41 people to the to help
was creating wealth in this country the
power tameness countryside rhyming is so
deep that it will probably take us to be
three decades with a strong reforms and
about when I will strong upon 17 the
rebound that we are seeing but much
stronger and much better than that for
India to become a supermodel superpower
does it mean fully insensibility this
thing which should I share was but the
wholesomeness is going to collapse
because it didn't have the kind until
they didn't actually care for their
whole people it was just a handful of
people on the talk to a controlling the
lies and creatures of their own
countrymen we as a democracy we spoke
parallel in the sense that we must be in
India have allowed political freedom but
we are not allowed on the freedom 14 and
we must have good
two go hand in hand after all economic
freedom is awful and for that we need to
do many